well hello to the ladies of season 13 of
rupaul's drag race
how does that feel amazing it's gonna
shake my titties
don't take my arms
hello e.t my name is denali i'm the ice
queen and vice princess of season 13.
nice to meet you all
and i am the scottish american rock star
i am tamisha iman and i am the matriarch
of the iman dynasty i'm a makeup queen
and i cannot wait to show you so much
more
hi you guys my name is elliott with two
t's and if you want to see me
kick myself in the face you gotta tune
in on new year's day i'm a sucker i'm
ready to give you the full
that i re-experienced darling hey y'all
it's me simone your first
arkansas queen and i'm so excited to
show you what the natural state has in
store for you
i'm tina berner and it's time for a
linebacker and address
it's turning inverted [ __ ] utica
queen
from utica minnesota 291 people and i'm
the one game that escaped
caught maura hall v mackie doll i'm here
to prove to you scheid and sparkle never
go out of style
i'm joey j and let me tell you you do
not need to necessarily have a wig on
to teach you how to do some good drag
hi everyone i am olivia lux the luminous
piano playing show girl
from new jersey currently residing in
brooklyn new york
it's me candy news
and i just want the viewers up there to
know that we are about to go on the wild
ride
you're gonna love me you're gonna hate
me about the end of the day you cannot
deny
[ __ ] you're gonna be obsessed with me i
love it what a sales pitch we're kicking
off with
six lip syncs for your lives for our
life on day one we've gotten a sneak
peek we're kicking this thing off with
six
lip syncs for our lives
when you heard that what was your
reaction face crack body crack
uh all the crack cocaine everything just
cold
yeah a hip crack i was like i could not
believe it that's the last thing i
thought was gonna happen on the first
day like whoa
crazy i was not reading i was physically
physically not ready
the bloodbath that's a good
right away wow to start the season off
with such a banger
i think it's really like it's gonna be
next it was
really shocking because you didn't
expect the second walking in to hear
rupaul's voice
from the main stage like anybody back me
up with this
girl what what
[Music]
there's only two of us what is going on
here
welcome my queens what you weren't
expecting to
see me so soon no ma'am every season
she's not even talking to you in your
entrance look so yeah i'm like i was
backstage like is that rupaul's saying
my
name right now right in full drag
yeah like full drag that's right full
drag
and it was crazy too just seeing all the
judges like
yeah just you know you don't expect that
you always
you always think that you know what to
expect when you come into the show
but every year they always say you have
no idea what's going on and you really
don't
to quote you know laganja oh y'all
wanted a twist
eh y'all wanted it and we're thinking oh
this is gonna be a cute normal day honey
like take your game plan and throw it
down the drain
crazy what should the audience be
prepared for the premiere would be like
no other season has had before and
that's why i say that it was like the
renaissance of drag because
season 13 was truly giving uh drivers to
facelift that i much needed
and you know you walk into the work room
and you expect they want to just be like
a regular drag race regularly at drag
race
but to walk in and be like all right
girls hi
we're here six lip syncs that's gagging
yeah in my opinion probably the most
exciting first episode of rupaul's drag
race ever
this whole season you definitely have to
be on your toes at all times
more than ever before because they for
sure they got us good many times
oh my gosh take a look around honey you
got some competition
where if you had to sum up this season
with one word what's your word
to describe season thirteen yeah honey
gag
psycho exhaustion
[Laughter]
lack of sleep one word lady historic
triumphant epic yeah everything about it
we have a crazy gag worthy premiere
the queens are gag worthy the looks are
gag worthy
like that's it you could just change the
name like rupaul's gag race
get your gag reflex going for rupaul's
guy i don't want to know how much
joey hasn't seen on that joke before how
long
[Laughter]
candy what's your word for season 13.
every speech live such a refreshing
season i think fans should just prepare
to have a good time